僕は芸人ではありません笑い芸人じゃないんですけども採決と体を張った動画を
ちょっと取りすぎて何からただのイカレポンチみたいになってるんですけどもそんな
ことはありません
普通にちょっと大学生に戻って共闘を取ろうと思いますみなさんご存知の通り
僕はシャーペンが大好きです確りはもう山ほどあるんですけども今手元にはまだこれで
くらいしかない
ねチャーて骨いいんだよフォースってでシャンテですこれ知らないからねうん某月聞い
ているサーフィンが好きだから
シャーペン減のことは僕よくわかんないんですけども今回のシャーペンというワークを
1個組だして新たな共通に僕は挑戦しようと思いますこちらし
パイロットの万年2
角野という名前でございますでわー
入ら空の角の舗装路ですねもう木の下でしょこのマンネップ
なんですよきっと角度が楽しくなるというキャッチフレーズで初めて晩年ピタッとよう
ですね三角グリップを握りやすい説明書が付いてる俺を積んでシャーペンを卒業するや
卒業しね卒じゃないんですけど
never ネッツはねぇかっこいいっすよああなにを言おうとかっこいいお酒ないん
ですけどもどれだけシャーペンが頑張ってもきっとたどり着くことができないくらい僕
の中でかっこいいというイメージがありますまあ燃費つその後と万年筆っていうものが
何なのかっていうまず話していきましょう万年筆のペン先は使えば使うほど自分の書き
方になじんで滑らかになっていきます
そして
使い続けた万年2は自分だけの自分に合ったリポへと成長します
成長する
だ
超ただ他の筆記具と違いバンネットではこの日の定理は戦場だの使い方が気を遣うこと
が大勢のイメージが3どちらかと言うと消え去り月に1機でもありますばかりはなんか
めんどくささおじいさんと過熱化プレイですね育てる晩年ぷつ愛着なる一方となり自分
の書き癖を覚えて育ちながら手に馴染んでいきますいいじゃないの
いいじゃない
布万年筆の魅力っていうのはペン先ですね
金属になっていますとりあえずちょっとよくわかんないんですそれだけてみましょう
これはもう姉あぼシャーペンの枠を超えるとカッコイーペン先の俺は惚れ惚れしちゃう
んですよ
こんな感じですし
これはこのペン先わかりますでしょうかこの鋭い感じがでもうた版がかっこよく見えて
きちゃったわけなんですよ
かっこいいよこれを見てて使い方を勉強していくわけがな使い方の気候歳といえば
大丈夫キャップを開けよう
腹にしてるのか後優しく引き抜いただけであるんですね超えて優しく聞きに行くことが
とても大事らしいです
ターンしてが大事なことかもしれないよ大事なことかもしれないカートリッジを
差し込もうこれですねここにまっすぐに差し込むことが大事いっぽいですねちょっとグ
ダって夏って笑顔の正空のある4を上にして書いてみましょう
ああこれはわかりやすいねこの映画をのある方を自分の向きにして書くと掛け合わせい
たシーンですねわかりやすいねそれ成長していく転居
こと聞いて部活って熱くなってるどうぞ多分インクが溜まってきたので書いてみましょ
とわっ
書きやすいなんとね変わって書やですねはれてないとでもうボールって子どさらさら
するわけじゃないんですけどもサラサラ書けるんですけども
じゃあまたペン先が僕に合ってないのかそれでも度も探さまたないです例えば持ってる
だけですねもっとかっこいいですね
いやー
はまった書き味としては全く問題ない
ナーベルで万人一だよなんてねこうタッチしづらいものかなと思ってたんですけども
実際使ってみてばいけないと思ってしまいました
大学生らしい動画に仕上がったようだ
うわぁ
p 主
ます
ばいばーい
これから
東京に行ってくるよ